apparently Democratic women report the
lowest levels of relationship
satisfaction uh you can see over here on
the chart I don't know does my cursor
show it doesn't really show on that yeah
it says women you know in the Republican
category completely satisfy satisfied is
reported as 42 out of this full uh list
over here and Democrat is 29. the other
ones are obviously very very satisfied
somewhat satisfied not too sad but
generally speaking it it seems like
women that lean more on the conservative
side are much happier in relationships
I'm going to assume it's because there
was more masculine men whereas Democrat
liberal type women tend to pick more
softer feminize you know the soy boys
sort of like Avatar type of guys and
they're reporting lower levels of
satisfaction the other thing too is I
think that you know when it comes to
political
opinions and ideology there's a pretty
clear you know to me anyway obvious
signs that
um there's a victim mindset that's
infused more in the Democrat type of
parties like everybody's oppressed
everybody's been taken advantage of no
accountability no ownership so it's no
surprise that the level of satisfaction
is reported quite low what did you guys
think about that I think what happens
with these people is they have fractured
identities a lot of times so I I came
across a girl yesterday out and about
talked to her for a bit and very clearly
it became abundantly clear quick and
very quickly that she was one of these
ister is or ISM type people and just
talking to her at one point I think I I
ended up discarding her pretty quickly
because again you vet these people out
girl or guy in your life to where I'm
like hey I don't like I'm not talking to
you I'm talking to like a programmed
version of you and she her identity was
so wrapped up in her politics and her
way of viewing the world that I I wasn't
even talk talking to her it was like
it's like an automaton or a robot that I
was engaging with and it's mentally
exhausting for me so normally I let I
let those conversation threads end or a
lot of times these chicks don't get the
hint and I end up for them and let her
be on her way but I think so many people
have fractured identities to where okay
let's say that I fly the flags or I
support black lives matter or whatever
the political issue du jour is and all
of a sudden you say something against it
well you're not only offending black
people you're offending me personally
because now I I'm a part of this Camp
I'm I I suffered as much as they did
just by posting something on Facebook or
Instagram so Pat me on the back look at
me where's my praise where's my
attention where's my validation and when
you don't give it to those people or
guys guys like us are like hey you
realize this kind of [__] right like
you guys went and burned down all your
cities and then you know the people who
launched this organization just kind of
[__] off with the money like no one
thinks about that oh that you that is a
declaration of war against him because
you were personally attacking and
pulling apart their identity which is
hanging on by a very very fine thread
exactly do you remember the article that
came out last month and it said that
um employers were screening resumes
based on the pronouns on the resumes so
if you put your pronouns on a resume
employers were essentially going yeah I
don't want to deal with this person
because I know I'm going to be bringing
identity politics into my office so it's
the same in relationships for any ladies
listening to this if you start off with
identity politics most men who have
options are going to be like yeah I'm
not going near that
yeah
it might be a different place to the
rest of the world
when I had the restaurant back in the
day I had two people
of
unusual sexual orientation let's call it
that they were very hard working they
were always on time they never give me
gave me lip service
and it was like they were
two of the people that I had the least
problems with they didn't stay for long
but when they were there they did their
job
and they weren't constantly trying to
create
mountains out of more Hills otherwise in
Romania regarding chicks like that I
just next like there's no reason like
maybe she if she's a 9.5 maybe I'll a
week and and try to do something over
there but otherwise
the juice is not worth the squeeze
yeah I don't I don't deal with anybody
with pronouns man I get loads of emails
and if something shows up with pronouns
I don't even care what the offer offer
is it's just block immediately like I'm
not dealing with these [__] easily
manipulated uh culturally woke uh folks
uh they're just not trustworthy you know
in my opinion you know because if they
can be manipulated that easily I just
can't trust them
and that's the Crux of it all because
you know that this person whatever the
next thing is this person is going to be
into it as soon as the next thing drops
they're into it yeah
yeah it's funny like you know Jake's
here on the chat he said and X broke up
with him because he didn't want to go to
a pride parade with her it's like like
that's that's where you set the boundary
like like send them off send them off
they'll they'll maybe figure it out one
day maybe they won't it doesn't matter
but like I always say don't make your
problems my problems it's very simple
you want to clean life you want a simple
life you want a pleasant happy life
don't let somebody with woke ideologies
and problems come into your life done
and men with options will do that you
know that's why Jake was able to say no
I'm good have fun enjoy it bye-bye
and and the thing is the walk ideology
they're not happy people like I spoke to
a friend of mine the other day who's
who's liberal he's classical liberal and
we we can have a lot of fun busting each
other's chops over politics
they're just not they're just they're
because to them the world is full of
Injustice and horrible stuff all the
time yeah you know they just can't see
beauty or enjoyment or fun or happiness
anywhere you know
um let's oh ma if you sent a video link
do you want me to put that up and play
it
it's like 54 seconds
you're muted by the way
yeah my computer's a little bit slow
yeah I thought that was just a funny
clip like if you want to deal like if
you want to put it up I mean it's about
50 seconds yeah all right hold on a
second let me uh
actually here I'll I'll switch over that
in a second since I got it already
queued up
um do you guys know who Esther perel is
um I met her in 2010 I sat at a table
with her you know she's done a couple of
TED Talks uh I've referenced a few of
her books and I follow her on Twitter
and this popped up in my feed the other
day so I want to share it with you it's
like a minute long video and she's
talking about can men can women and men
be friends so check this out
uh let me just back it up here and
volume on play can men and women be
friends absolutely absolutely and this
is also a real cultural thing because I
know that in the US when you put
friendships between men and women on on
on a search you're going to get
immediately no not possible totally
sexualized all the time it's you can't I
don't believe it I don't think it's true
I think that there are deep friendships
between all types of people certainly
between men and women identified and
life long and they can coexist with
another with the primary romantic
relationship
um and I honestly think that it's very
very good it's really important you know
I they make sense that they should have
girlfriends that are not their
girlfriends so that when they have
questions about a girlfriend they
actually have another female friend that
they can go and talk to as well as male
friends for that matter
is so important um I don't I I have
spent a lot of time wondering why this
was seen as so impossible why does
everything have to be sexualized and
part of it has to do with this country's
attitude towards sexuality that then
describes friendship between men and
women as impossible so I'm quite clear
on this one I wish it for all
so I find that interesting because you
know she says why does everything have
to be sexualized I can't remember who
the gentleman was that quoted it but
it's widely regarded by most academics
like this that everything in the world
is about sex except for sex sex is about
power
um now I comment on this and said you
know you can park your exotic car in a
[__] neighborhood overnight leave it
unlocked and find it in the morning
absolutely but chances are it'll be
damaged or we're stolen I think that
some of this might be ego investments in
her beliefs because of her age I don't
know how old she is she she's probably
close to 60 now and her smv
um obviously you know doesn't exist I
think any guy that would want to be
friends with her is probably for like an
academic reason or for a promotion
um so it probably doesn't compute but
I'm still of the position that men and
women can't be friends at I mean if
she's attractive and you're friends with
her you're going to want a banger it's
as simple as that and it's funny Rich
you mentioned it so to debunk her
argument for these people on the left
the the entire world is based on haves
and have-nots Victor or the the victim
mentality versus the oppressors any of
that everything all is about a power
exchange in their ideology sex is about
a power exchange and they make that
argument usually very clearly and then
out of the same mouth they say well but
male female relationships they can be
purely platonic because ones have to be
about sex they know it's about a power
exchange and they know that in those
types of relationships they are they
have the power as females and are
extracting extra yeah extracting
resources from the guys with whom they
enter those platonic type friendships
that's precisely why you don't do that
type of thing and even in like
interpersonal relationships I've had
I'll say admittingly yeah I have a
couple of platonic girlfriends but
that's because they're girls I'm not
attracted to and I know that in these
relationships there is a power exchange
where one of them wants something more
from the other than the others willing
to give them and in that case I've I
have had girls in the past or co-workers
where you can tell they want something
more out of you and you maintain the
power by not giving that to them but
usually in those relationships it's the
girl extracting power
resources or yeah deriving Power by
extracting time money resources energy
from the guy that's precisely why so she
cut with her ideology of world view they
kind of pull apart their argument also
in the sense that it's all about power
that's why you don't do it I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out